da kommen wir jetzt zu einem äußerst
brutalen und schockierende video aus den
usa ist zeigt zwei polizisten die opfer
werden einer ganz schlimm und grausamen
bluttat samstagabend gegen 19 uhr
ortszeit in los angeles vor ort kampen
ein unbekannter angreifer geht auf ein
polizeiauto zu zieht plötzlich eine
pistole zieht aufs band zielt aufs
beifahrerfenster und drückt ab die
schüsse fallen offensichtlich ohne jede
vorwarnung komplett unprovoziert eiskalt
die beiden beamten im wagen eine 31
jährige polizistin und ein 24 jähriger
kollege werden laut behördenangaben
beide mehrfach getroffen und beide
schweben leider auch in lebensgefahr